The elements in a great recipe really
very,
again,
according to culture and each one will
give you a different answer,
but I think is a,
again,
the prime product as a chef,
I need to have the best that I can,
the best that nature can give me in the
product,
then my work as the chef is not to alter
that have to change,
but to exalt.
So in doing that I may need some
condiments which is olive oil or butter
or whatever.
I might need some seasoning to enhance
it,
whether it's sold spices or herbs,
but basically gave me good product from
nature and most of my work.
Is that right?
I,
you know,
it's difficult.
It's difficult to isolate a.
I think what I would like to say is that
I love cooking and eating seasonally.
Therefore,
following the season,
what does the bounty of the season
brained?
And I enjoy that at the given time.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
um,
if you,
if I were to really choose one MSA pasta
and vegetables,
that would have to be.